bonsoir alain gautier merci de répondre
à nos questions s'il s'avère que paris a
bien laissé filer les génocidaires qui
était dans une zone contrôlée par
l'armée française
comment expliquer que la france ait agi
de la sorte
je crois que il n'y a pas de véritable
explication
le gouvernement fait de 1994 a toujours
été du côté des forces armées rwandaises
toujours du côté des partisans du
président habyalimana et que cela s'est
manifesté
déjà bien avant le génocide mais pendant
le génocide par des livraisons d'armes
et le nom de la débâcle des génocidaires
en refusant en particulier de les
désarmer love qu'ils se sont réfugiés au
zaïre et qu'il faut continuer la lutte
en serait embêtant dans les camps pour
promet de revenir au rwanda
le chercheur françois grin heures a
qualifié ce document comme je cite la
pièce écrite manquantes
une pièce essentielle du puzzle est ce
que ça peut faire évoluer les enquêtes
judiciaires en cours
je ne fais pas tu vas pas à vanter les
choses c'est très bien que françois
granet repectivement ait pu découvrir ce
document mais lieu depuis très longtemps
nous ne prêtons de dénoncer ce cas peut
être le rôle du gouvernement empêche de
1994 dans le génocide des tutsi du
rwanda
nous ce qui nous donnerait à nous ils
firent haute sphère apple a livré hier
le président c'était françois mitterrand
et le premier ministre était edouard
balladur oui c'est faire l' effet un
gouvernement de coalition
mais on aimait tremper dans ceux de
tanks et des fusions là est jeune il
encore pouvoir en france je pense à
hubert védrine alain juppé et tout eu
toutes les découvertes on pourra faire
dans les archives et bien seront
toujours les bienvenus pour venir
conforter des idées que nous avons déjà
et des connaissances que nous avons
déjà sur le rôle du gouvernement en fait
de 1994 et que risquent les responsables
français qui était en poste à l'époque
où malheureusement j'ai bien peur qu'ils
ne risquent pas grand chose à moins que
certaines personnes courageuses ne
défile de déposer des plaintes non
collectif des particuliers
si vous voulez nous poursuivons plutôt
en justice ceux qui ont bénéficié de ce
nom d armement des génocidaires puisque
en refusant de désarmer ceux qui avaient
commis le génocide des tutsi eh bien on
a vu affluer ici en france un nombre
important de gimeux thibert que nous
tentons de traîner devant la justice
mais la justice française est
extrêmement lente et les génocidaires
que nous voulons faire juger sont
utilisées a eu l'idée abusent de toutes
les procédures qui leur seront permis le
pépère et quels sont vos espérances
alors enfin on espère que alors lieu il
ya cpe
cette découverte vient de prendre le
crâne et il y aura d'ici quelques
semaines
le rapport de monsieur duclair suite à
la commission que monsieur macron à
constituer wafi deux ans je ne fais pas
trop sur quoi on va aboutir on va
attendre c'est ce rapport de la
commission et on verra ce qu'il faut est
ce qu'on pourra tenter contre les
responsables politiques de 1994 et sur
l'euro de paris avant pendant et après
le génocide des tutsi il existe encore
des zones d'ombré non on n'y croit pas
véritablement ceux qui connaissent bien
le sujet
schalke depuis très longtemps la france
le gouvernement en fait soutient le
régime qui a été un régime génocidaire
le président mitterrand a soutenu son
ami le président habyalimana avant que
ce dernier ne soit abattu dans son avion
et puis ce gouvernement à continuer
pendant génocide à soutenir soutenir ce
gouvernement le gouvernement intérimaire
gouvernements bailleurs qui a été
constituée il faut le rappeler dans les
locaux de l'ambassade de france
et puis continue encore aujourd'hui à
soutenir les gens qui ont participé au
génocide en particulier dans tt faire du
double génocide que de nombreux
politiques est en fait continue encore
aujourd'hui à profiter est ce que vous
êtes en est quelque chose de la
communauté internationale de l'onu
notamment par exemple ont
personnellement je n'attends pas grand
chose je le vois pas ce que leurs nuls
viendrait apporter de plus
je crois que c'est une affaire qu'il
faut essayer de régler entre les deux
états entre les deux gouvernements non
franchement l'onu n'a pas n'a pas montré
qu'elle était à la hauteur de
l'événement du génocide des tutsi donc
je crois qu'il ne faut pas il ne faut
pas arriver par rapport à la gouvernance
internationale
merci alain gautier d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le cofondateur du collectif des parties
civiles pour le rwanda